comme a fléchi de neuville professeur de
géopolitique spécialiste de l'iran
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors après cinq ans
de rupture des relations diplomatiques
on sent bien que bram à de belles salles
même temps la main à l'iran est ce que
vous pensez qu'ils ne veut vraiment
apaiser les tensions avec la république
islamique quel est son objectif
principal selon vous il existe toujours
une concurrence c'est contre l'arabie
saoudite et d'héroïne aurions de
puissances rivales de puissance qui
s'opposent aux deux versions
linguistiques historiques religieuses
aussi les deux puissances qui sont dans
deux camps de géo politiques opposées
puisque depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale l'arabie saoudite est
massivement soutenu par les états unis
le l'arabie saoudite avait joué le
président 30
elles avaient massivement financer sa
campagne présidentielle et donc à
l'élection de son rival joe biden
l'arabie saoudite voit ses relations
avec les etats-unis se détendre et elle
se rapproche mécaniquement d'autres
puissances ça peut être la russie s'est
aussi viron qui est une opposé mais il
faut pour pas point esquissé un dialogue
avec ses opposants
d'ailleurs ceux des looks avait commencé
avant même l'élection de joe biden
puisque l'on se souvient de l'assassinât
du général soleimani en irak s'étaient
assis là étaient liées justement au fait
que ce général préparer en sous-main un
rapprochement en tonneaux et l'arabie
saoudite
un rapprochement qui aurait fait qu'ils
auraient recomposer la géopolitique du
moyen heureux on sent bien quand même
que depuis l'élection de joe biden
l'heure est plutôt au nez plus la
confrontation avec téhéran au contraire
c'est plutôt une détente entre les
etats-unis l'iran puisque les états unis
veulent revenir sur l accord nucléaire
iranien et en même temps la ramade ben
salman qui engagent un dialogue avec
téhéran est ce qu'il ya une coïncidence
concernant le timing justement
effectivement ccir fait une séquence où
des kanaks fois les etats-unis se sait
jouer de l'arabie saoudite
et puis il s'engage un dialogue avec
l'iran
en fait il renaît en fait ils reprennent
le dialogue cbt commencer par vous même
avec l'hérault et donc ils s'acheminent
vers une petite détente des relations
irano américaines
ce ne sera pas une réconciliation mais
l'iran et d'un point de vue géopolitique
bancaire il est plutôt des mangas
l'écart et c'est petit et on va
permettre à l'iran de lever les
sanctions d'humanité a sauté sur lui et
de recommencer en souvent et à petit des
vies les affaires donc effectivement il
ya bien un lien il n'y avait bien
aujourd'hui on a un léger doute
positionnement les états unis dans la
région et moi et ben ben salman et ses 2
n'existe plus grâce à ce regret
sciemment lui qui est très critiquée en
interne en arabie saoudite
lui qui a fait lever contre lui beaucoup
d'opposants
lui qui avait également choisi par les
américains pour succéder à son père
alors qu'il n'y a pas de règles de
succession fixe aux troubles en arabie
saoudite appelle ce genre de relation
peut-on s'attendre entre l'arabie
saoudite est l iran dans un futur proche
et bien un peu au pôle septembre ce qui
serait le sauveur d'un rapprochement se
serait développé des relations
diplomatiques
je pense qu'on va commencer par des
discussions en sous-main des discussions
assez informelle naturellement il y
avait des intérêts mutuels et notamment
gaziers et pétroliers à pouvoir agir de
concert mais ce serait bête en échec
tout
politique israélienne et américaine dans
la région
donc il va falloir du temps pour que les
six opposants géopolitique s'accordent
sur certains points et s'accordent ils
vont ils tentent de s'accorder ils se
rencontrent eux tout tout le jeu
diplomatique des puissances qui n'ont
aucun intérêt à votre choix dernière
question on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de
conflits régionaux qui les opposent
notamment le yémen qu'en est il sur
cette question est ce que là aussi on
pourrait s'attendre à un apaisement
justement entre les deux puissances
régionales
effectivement le mot ben maxwell
aujourd'hui il modifie sa posture didier
ben loulou où il mène on peut dire que
l'arabie saoudite et l'iran soutiennent
de quand vous aimez les souvenirs sont
embourbés aux accompli où ils ont joué
exclusivement la technologie militaire
plus de l'intelligence humaine et les
militaires dans ce conflit et ils sont
aujourd'hui dans une logique il faut
appels de plus en plus de nouveaux
contrats d'armement mais vise uniquement
à des solutions technologiques pour
résoudre un problème politique solution
qui est en fait une arme blanche et
william l effectivement on sent que ça
va nous réjouir un rôle d'apaisement
actuellement pour modifier un peu la
posture d'arabie saoudite
ça pourrait être un premier endroit deux
premiers buts de négociations entre les
deux parties opposées
merci beaucoup en tout cas dans ma fille
ne viennent d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur en géopolitique et
spécialiste de l'iran